okay so it was an epic night at last
night's acm honors at the iconic ryman
auditorium in nashville with the
ceremony celebrating special awards
recipients including miranda lambert
chris stapleton and canadian country
queen shania twain among many others
let's go girls yeah so shania was
honored with the acm poets award and
blew us all away on the red carpet look
at this in this plunging black velvet
gown oh my gosh she looks so good
featuring a nostalgic leopard print
cowboy hat which looks like it's right
out of the music video for that don't
impress me much
but they're so good even more nostalgic
well listen before i go on like you
can't look at leopard print and not
think of her it's so true in that
beautiful video
you have to anyways there was even more
nostalgia in the fashion department
country star kelsey ballerini turned
heads wearing the exact same white gown
that shania wore to the 99 grammy awards
where the canadian superstar took home
two trophies for her hit still the one
yeah i love this so shania is all for
giving her iconic dress new life it was
a real pinch me moment for kelsey and an
even bigger compliment for shania
this dress is the iconic dress that
shania twain wore in 1999 when she swept
the grammys um and we got it out of the
grammy museum 24 hours ago
we just had our fingers crossed that it
would fit because obviously we would not
alter a thing about it um and it did and
so
it's another way that i get to like
honor her tonight and her legacy oh my
god
you know i saw kelsey in the dress
and
i was just it was it's so stunningly
beautiful on her and what it says so
much
about
you know it's not about
it's not about the dress
it's about
where how to wear that feeling and so
you know that for me it was you know big
brownie nights and the memory splashed
back and it was you know positive
memories
and so now that is care it's like the
dress came back alive again
through her
and
it's just wonderful it's a huge
compliment
a lot of positive energy in that dress
okay kelsey later opened the show
honoring shania with the performance of
man i feel like a woman alongside
shania's dancers from vegas oh my gosh
this is amazing the whole thing the
whole deal the hat and everything i know
and of course the salutes to shania
didn't stop with just one outfit kelsey
wore a replica of the top hat and tail
coat tie ensemble that shania of course
wore in her music video for the hit
and you know what that does impress us
that does impress us we have comments
sorry i was saying love shine tween she
is a legend and still looks gorgeous
okay i'm back is saying you really can't
go wrong with a white streamlined gown
agreed oh my gosh look at that someone
say the guy on the bottom i guess our
bottom right yeah he's just in it he's
living eyes closed
living in the moment feeling this
they're all so sweaty uh
put those in the grammy museum i love it
yazzy's sang
look at this a celebrity wearing someone
else's dress and it actually fits them
there you go
uh hs is saying positive energy in life
helps a lot i love this uh you know
shania twain we were just talking about
this not only changed the face of
country music but then watching her go
beyond
the country genre i was talking about
how she did the music video for notting
hill you have to understand away you
have to understand before the show
started today we were going over the
stories and we're talking about shania
twain and morgan's like do you remember
this music video so and we basically
watched the whole music video i made it
we lived our youth it's amazing do you
guys remember you've got away she's
wearing that beautiful gown with the
flowers on the swing and there's little
bits of notting hill put in the music
video she's the blue eye makeup 1999
hello and it makes you remember like
not that you forget that she's an icon
but that
you know
back in the late 90s
there were only a handful of people that
really got to have their moment
and really got to make this mark where
they influence so much of what comes
after them and that's our girl right
there and before like social media where
you're seeing everyone's videos on tick
tock and instagram i mean music videos
that was it like so music videos were
so massive you would wait like they
would they would let you know they'd be
like this is us this is aging ourselves
oh god i know i'm sorry they would tell
you like okay wednesday night 7 p.m
they're dropping the new video for
whoever shania's new video and you'd
watch it on tv you're legit one or you'd
get someone to set the vcr for you in my
house it was me because i'm the nerd i
was the vcr but yeah i love it solo
studios is saying shania is a legend
nods to her classic videos they're
always great it's so true and the office
i get what she's saying there you know
it's not just about the open it's how
you feel in them and but like that
classic should i have to
be like oh it's not just about the dress
it's not about me it's about wearing
that canadian there we go again talking
about canadian celebrities
uh yeah and uh
okay i'm back is saying giving me
flashbacks of the jlo super bowl
interesting
oh mossy saying yeah when much music
actually played music i had to say that
i did